time to get ready for the playoffs good
to be with tony and rodney and mike
i am still tony i haven't left this spot
i've been in the basement now for nine
days so i'm a little stirred crazy
so really i am so happy you guys i may
keep you here for an hour it's so nice
to have people and see
see my guys and feel comfortable here
you don't pay that well mike
i do thanks very much i appreciate it
way to help out a friend you know
i'm in quarantine in the basement that's
what i get from rodney but we're all
hanging and doing okay
hey uh really excited for the four games
this is always we say the best weekend
of the football season right
so let's start with our game on saturday
night it's baltimore going up to buffalo
a little bit of snow in the forecast
uh rodney i'll let you kick off the
conversation here because baltimore's
defense stepped up in the second half
against tennessee
now they're gonna have to step up
against a very different and very
explosive offense in buffalo
yeah just got off the phone phone with
kayla's campbell and he said
i asked him about the snow and the
potential of snow and he said look we're
not concerned about that
we're playing good physical football
right now they have a lot of respect for
josh allen
and really when you when what the the
majority of our conversation was about
josh allen
and trying to keep him in the pocket not
allowing him to escape they have a lot
of respect for josh allen
but the main thing he told me for the 10
or 15 minutes that i spend time with him
is
we have to make sure that we tackle josh
allen
and to me that's kind of been the
interesting thing looking at baltimore
and buffalo
because in buffalo's game lamar jackson
had to step up
as a passer as tennessee was trying to
take him away as a runner
and then in the buffalo game josh allen
became a runner they hadn't really used
him a lot on design
runs all year but that became a big part
of their offense so it's these two
quarterbacks
uh they're definitely going to be the
bell cows and how are they going to lead
their teams
on saturday and that's one thing that
fascinates me about this because both
defenses are used to seeing a
quarterback who can move
so it's not some foreign thing to them
that they're going to be rattled by
they know it from practice they've
studied it they've seen it and i think
that makes them a little bit
better equipped to deal with the other
team's mobile quarterback but yeah for
lamar jackson it's got to be
more diversification of the offense like
we saw on sunday against the titans with
marquis brown involved
like we've never seen him before and i
think that was a great great
development for the bills and they're
gonna need more of that if they want to
win
i'm gonna watch really early in this
game for even the pregame
if it is snowing a little bit and there
is an inch or so of snow in the forecast
i want to see how lamar jackson runs
confidently and moves around
do you remember the monday night game
they played at cleveland he had a ton of
problems with his shoes and everything
else
we know his speed and his elusiveness is
important he hasn't practiced in the
snow
he's never played in the snow i'll be
really curious to see
how that impacts him and rodney and tony
i'd love for you guys to weigh in on
this
you know for baltimore and lamar it was
about getting the win so there's not the
conversation of he hasn't won a playoff
game
and for buffalo it had been the 25 years
since winning the division and all that
stuff
now that they both did something does
that make it easier
or harder as they take the next step
that really tough step
and winning the divisional round tony
i'll let you go first
i i think it makes it easier you do get
that monkey off your back and you don't
have to worry about that anymore now
you're just worried about the other team
and preparing for them so i think we're
going to see the best
of both teams for sure
i look at lamar and i think if if you
haven't had
experience playing in the snow if you
haven't been out there
i think it causes a lot of players
problems you you saw what happened um to
what team was that that went into green
bay that was tennessee that went into
green bay
and they looked a total they looked a
total mess so i think lamar is going to
struggle
and as much even if they have success
running the football
he still he still will be forced to make
a few plays down the field
where where he's got to open up that
offense and
right now i'm just really concerned but
when i look at buffalo's defense and
just watching that defense coach and i
don't know how much tape you watch
they're very vulnerable up the middle if
you run straight down their throat you
can gain big yards and
and i think that's going to be the story
of the game
let me just say real quickly too the
difference between josh allen and lamar
jackson getting their first playoff wins
i feel like the bills got grazed by the
colts
that the colts outplayed them when you
look at the numbers and it was josh
allen who stepped up and got it done
but it wasn't an easy win we had seen
the bill's dominant dominant dominant
dominant and then they got rattled by
the seventh seed
the ravens on the other hand they have
been winning and winning and winning
with their backs against the wall they
went into tennessee and beat the titans
there
i think they come out of it with more of
a lift than the bills do the bills just
have to feel like
what happened it all could have ended i
think they may have less confidence
going into this game than they would
have had and the ravens confidence is
through the roof
hey floria i don't think the bills are
sitting back worried about
they they understand that this is the
playoffs and whether you win by 20 or
whether you won by three points a win is
a win
and now you go from the wild card game
to the divisional game i just think
they're not focused on how badly you
know or or how impressive they looked
against the cults
it's about here now both these teams are
very confident and we saw just from how
buffalo acts
whether they're in the end zone they
make a big play they're having fun
they're encouraging one another they're
cheering one another on so i i don't
think buffalo has an issue with
the way they won i just i just know that
they're happy that they won
and i want to get tony back to one point
before we move on to the next game
and that's john harbaugh tony you have
coached in the playoffs you've gone on
the road in the playoffs
just how incredible the numbers have
been for john harbaugh
on the road over these years winning
playoff games
i don't think people realize how
difficult it is that's one of the the
toughest things
in the world is to win road playoff
games because you're playing against the
higher seed
and you're playing against a team that
is confident at home
and and plays well so for john to take
these teams on the road
year after year after year and win games
it's just phenomenal but i think it
speaks to their mentality and rodney
talked about it
this is a confident team buffalo is
going to be confident but
i guarantee you baltimore is going to be
confident as well we can go on the road
and win and we don't care where it is
that's exactly how his demeanor was he's
like look they have stefan diggs they
have josh allen he is fantastic he was
very complimentary
but at the end of the day they believe
in themselves they believe in that
defense
brandon williams is back liz campbell's
back they feel like and
you look at the cornerback situation we
talk about indianapolis you compare
indianapolis colts
cornerbacks to the baltimore ravens
cornerbacks and that's going to be a big
story but the ravens plant they're
playing like i said they're playing with
a lot of confidence they're playing
physical
and i don't think buffalo i think
buffalo is going to be a one-dimensional
team i don't think buffalo can come out
and run the ball against these guys i
just i don't see that happening mike
florio
mike i'm going to give you the first
swing at the next game at cleveland and
kansas city in the early window
on sunday and another quarterback from
that draft class and baker mayfield
three from the same draft class that
also had sam darnold and josh rosen
will in the first round uh kansas city
has been waiting on the sidelines
for as thrilling and as awesome as the
cleveland story and
start of the game was you wake up to the
reality that
the best team in the afc had their feet
up last week they've been rested
and they're ready to go i'm fascinated
about this one what are you what are
your first thoughts on browns at chiefs
well i mean i would love for it to be
like the patrick mahomes baker mayfield
game from 2016. final score is 66.59 i
don't think it's going to be that though
that's right but
and and look what the browns need to do
and we talked last week about what the
colts needed to do against the bills you
got to limit the possessions of a great
offense there's a clear talent gap
between the chiefs and the browns so and
the browns have the running game
and they need to convince baker mayfield
you can't beat gunslinger with patrick
mahomes you have to be
game manager in this one and we've got
to keep patrick mahomes on the sideline
we've got to grind it out we've got to
shorten the game we've got to limit
their number of possessions that's the
only way to keep them under 30 points
is to limit the number of times that the
chiefs are on the field and try to use
that offense to just
slowly churn get a field goal when you
can get a touchdown when you can
and hope that you can find a way to
outscore the chiefs that to me is the
only way the browns can pull it off
and even then it's an uphill climb
coach well i would uh tend to disagree
with mr florio a little bit
patrick mahomes the chiefs have lost one
game in a year and a half
and they lost that game when the other
team scored 40 points
so if i'm cleveland that's what i'm
thinking about going in there hey my
defense hopefully we can get it done
hopefully we can make some plays like we
did against pittsburgh but you know what
we're going to need points and so chubb
kareem hunt my running backs they've got
to run the ball they've got to be
explosive i'm going to have to hit some
passes
and we're going to have to score
touchdowns we're probably going to have
to win this game 35-31
and offenses is going to have to do it
if this were a legal proceeding i would
be asking the court reporter to mark the
spot in the record where the hall of
fame defensive coach
advocates a shootout
that's the only way you're going to have
a chance because you these guys are
rested the last two weeks you're not
going to stop them from scoring
patrick mahomes isn't sitting on that
couch he can't wait to get back on that
football field
and i agree with coach wholeheartedly
baker mayfield and yes you can run the
ball and try to milk the clock but at
the end of the day you got to score
touchdowns and you got to score
a bunch of them if you want to compete
against those guys
so noted counselor rodney i just want to
come back to you on one part of this
deal here
what cleveland did last week you know
you're in the locker rooms
you know what it's like when players
band together and get something special
from afar just watching that you could
feel
adrenaline within you if you weren't a
steelers fan for what cleveland
accomplished
as a player watching that you were there
what did cleveland accomplish
in your eyes by doing that against all
odds on sunday night in pittsburgh
well first of all i mean if i were if i
were a guy in
pittsburgh i would have just pulled juju
smith schuster to the side and said like
what are you doing
what an idiotic statement you know it
was just such a disrespectful
and an unnecessary comment this is 11-5
team they deserve to be in the playoffs
and have their opportunity
and when you watch them on tape this is
a good football team so
it was just you know it's just one of
those things where you just
you feel like you know juju and the
pittsburgh steelers really took
the cleveland browns for granted and
cleveland they accomplished a whole lot
not having your coach not having your
start in secondary
and just the way those guys banded
together they became a
team that's what they accomplished here
i know winning the wild card game is a
significant thing for them
but just coming together more and being
that team that they can trust one
another
in those tight situations the the guy
named comment that baker mayfield made
after the game to michelle safoy that
that just like
defined what that game was all about and
they get a bunch of the players back off
the coveted list and they get kevin
stefanski back and
mike as rodney kind of pointed me in
that direction a few weeks ago kind of a
coach of the year type season go ahead
rox
yeah i was wondering like why didn't you
why
would coach florio you weren't there
they i think they picked pittsburgh to
win
i think rodney harrison was the only one
that
picked the cleveland browns against all
odds
to step up despite everybody
despite the head coach being in the
basement
against a hall of fame future coach
say what you want mike that was the
biggest win of the year i have to pat
myself on the back
wait but america also picked cleveland
which means rodney no longer hates
america
that's true and and what i like what i
like the most about that comment right
there
is the old school guy you trust just
stop the entire proceeding to say look
at me
and point to the name on the back jersey
so that's good that's really good
you see 2021 is different
this has taught me well i stopped that
so rodney i'm going to say this in all
honesty rodney you
you opened my eyes to a possibility that
i think is going to become the reality i
was thinking
for sure one way with my vote for coach
of the year
and you brought up kevin stefanski we
were talking about this after week 16
before week 17
and i think with the way things went in
miami and the way things finished in
cleveland a lot of folks did change
their vote
mike we're at the coaching season now
there are seven openings as we go
through this whatever process
as you watch this i you brought up a
great point that i'd love for you to
point out to everybody and bring up with
coach dungey here
well i you know and this is something
that coach dungey raised and i think it
makes a ton of sense we we have we have
cookie cutter molds for
who who coaches are going to be who are
going to be successful and coach you
mentioned john harbaugh earlier
i mean this wasn't a traditional hire
and it just seems like so many of these
owners continue
to demand something that is traditional
instead of thinking creatively
and maybe getting a guy that's going to
be their coach for 10 15 20 years
no i've talked to a couple general
managers i've talked to a couple of
owners over this process and everybody
who where can i get the sizzle how can i
get my fan base excited
i've got to get the hottest offensive
coordinator i've got to get the hottest
defensive coordinator
in the playoffs and it it really
when you look at who has been effective
and who's done the job
it's those people that can lead men who
can change
cultures and i remember talking to ozzie
newsome and he said you know what
john harbaugh was just what i was
looking for i was looking for
a leader and yes he was only the special
teams coach but i didn't care about that
well ozzy knows
newsom knows football and that to me is
is the big thing and
and we've got to get away from that
kevin stefanski
didn't come in and fix baker mayfield
kevin stefanski changed the whole
culture in cleveland he went from
hey we've got the number one draft
choice quarterback to you know what
we're going to keep track of how many
times on offense we knock defenders down
and we're going to be physical and we're
going to be a team and we aren't going
to care if we don't have our head coach
and we don't have our best offensive
linemen
and we don't have our secondary we're
the cleveland browns we're a team
that kind of mentality that's what
you've got to get across that's what
coaches do
and that can come from anywhere that
doesn't have to be
the offensive coordinator who who calls
all these plays that's what i think
we've got to get owners to understand
yeah mike and i coach absolutely right
when you look at kevin stefanski he's
not with his personality and his
demeanor
he's not that coach that's going to walk
in and throw chairs or anything like
that
when he's doing his interviews he's nice
and calm he has a
real calming demeanor just like you it's
in and the thing that i like about him
he holds everyone accountable but he
also
he respects the guys in that locker room
and when a coach respects you and you
feel like
you know you have the attention of the
coach and the coach is open-minded the
players are communicate with the coach
and the coach respect the players the
players respect the coach
and he's taken away all those negative
distractions you don't hear
those comments you don't hear baker
mayfield saying something crazy or
anything like that
these guys are 100 focused and the
reason why they were so successful is
because of the foundation that kevin
stefanski laid
that's why he was able to sit in the
basement and they were able to run the
ball and do some of the things some of
the basic things that they do it's
because of the coach he is hands down
the coach of the year he has been
absolutely fantastic go ahead mike
floria i know you scroll yeah let me
know
i wanted to chime in on on this notion
of the coaching hiring process because
you know it comes up from time to time
that that guys don't
don't interview well and whether it was
bruce arians who's kind of gruff and
says what he wants and mike zimmer
who's very in your face and tells it
like it is and it took them years to
find a head coaching job
and now you got eric b enemy like why
can't he get serious consideration
and i wish that these owners would
realize you're not hiring someone to sit
and talk in a board room
for an hour and a half you're hiring
someone to lead a locker room full of
football players
and you need to watch how they interact
with their players watch eric the enemy
on the sidelines of a game
you can see that he connects with his
players listen to what patrick mahomes
says about eric b enemy you can hear it
in his voice that he believes in eric b
enemy
so this whole interview process to me i
think all too often the owners lose
sight of the fact that
what the guy says and what he does when
he's in a suit and tie and he's
uncomfortable and it's an
hour and a half of talking and it's not
what he does for a living
and and it just astounds me that the
model continues
down that path when it's obvious that
that has nothing to do with what a guy
is going to do when he's a coach
mike i would say tony i was an assistant
coach for 15 years
and i heard that over and over i didn't
interview well
and to me that just means the owner
didn't like me
and that's okay you didn't like my style
but don't say i didn't interview well
because that had nothing to do with it
you didn't like the way i am and there's
nothing wrong with that
but eric the enemy not interviewing well
or a certain coach not interviewing well
uh that that's just a fallacy
i would say this as we pivot to the nfc
and you look at the higher in green bay
and matt lafleur who's been 13-3 these
two years and sean mcvay
who's had success i think some of the
really good hires
happen with the ownership and team
presidents
who are around their locker room who get
a feel for a guy who would be a good
leader of men
those who are in business it doesn't
mean that they can't hire good coaches
but they're used to dealing with
the ceo the corporate part of it you get
the guys who get a sense of the room and
somebody i've seen this
trait in this coach in our our group his
players play really well for him those
may be the guys who
have a good sense you think of steve
bashady like that with the higher of
harvest and relying on ozzie newsom like
you said tony rely on the football guys
because they got a sense they've been
there they've been led by bad coaches
they've been led by good coaches let me
spin to the rams in green bay
and this playoff game of here's sean
mcvay who got to the super bowl with a
terrific offense and now
they're riding the number one defense
and they're gonna have their hands full
with a great matchup with the number one
offense in aaron rodgers rodney as we
lay out the rams against the packers
what are your first thoughts
my first thoughts are you know i don't
know if aaron donald
is 100 healthy but they're going to
definitely need him but even if they
don't
have him at 100 i think they're still
going to be
okay they're not going to be as good as
they would be obviously with aaron
donald at 100
because other guys on the rams have
stepped up and played well on that
defensive front
leonard um floyd he's been great the
secondary is playing extremely well so
if i'm the rams i feel pretty confident
from a defensive standpoint coming in
there
i think their biggest challenge will be
aj dylan
aaron jones in the passing game i think
green bay he's fresh he's healthy
he's been off the last couple weeks i
think they're going to give him
more opportunities as a you know running
back lined up
as a wide receiver and i'm looking
really looking forward to just seeing
aaron rodgers and if they could protect
rogers
it could get ugly well everybody's going
to say
the rams have no chance warm weather
team going into lambeau field
and going without your quarterback or
jared goff being
injured but they have the right formula
rodney talked about it those pass
rushers
they've got a secondary they can cover
they can play defense
and then on the other side of the ball
even if jared goff can't go
they can run the football which has been
the achilles heel of
of green bay so i think it's a neat
matchup it depends on two things to me
aaron donald's health that's critical
he's got to be himself
and then number two they've got to be
able to deal with the elements they've
got to go in there mentally and say you
know what it is going to be cold but we
can go do this
no snow by the way mid 20s and cloudy by
the way so not terrible great mike
rip off the sleeves bud grant style no
coats on the sideline that's the way to
do it the way the minnesota teams used
to but i got two things on this
one if they put jalen ramsey on devante
adams and say you take care of him will
aaron rodgers still see a window and
still throw it in there because
you know with aaron rodgers accuracy you
could still find a crease
where you could get the ball in if
ramsey otherwise has them covered and
secondly aaron jones
contract year 24 teams home watching
this game this is his chance to get paid
by
somebody and the packers need that
running game to to
kind of open up the passing game because
other than devonta adams who do they
have
so those are the two key players for me
yeah that's what i'm going to watch will
they match up will that be an island and
a fun one to watch where you visit a few
times and then it becomes
robert tonyan mvs marquez valdez
scantling
uh maybe both backs at the same time
with one split out like rodney was
talking about
fascinating choices for green bay on
offense if you think
ramsay and adams are going to go over
here and have a terrific battle that we
could sell
on pay-per-view one more guys tampa bay
new orleans
uh tony did you say enough nice things
about the buccaneers when you got home
was everybody happy that you uh
you gave them all the plaudits and
credits for the win in washington
no they weren't happy with me i tried to
talk about how well they played what a
great game plan todd bowles had
how good tom brady was but they said all
i talked about was taylor heinecke and
and i did he was fantastic but uh i
think the quarterback that the bucks are
going to play this week is going to be a
little bit better than taylor heinecke
so we'll see it should be a great
matchup with drew brees and tom brady
yeah and to me i look at antonio brown
man he's just been so impressive he's
been their best wide receiver the last
month of the season
they're getting them involved moving
them around giving them different
opportunities
i look for him to continue his
fascinating play
and you know tom brady just seems very
comfortable with him right now
well and think about the last two saints
games week one right out of the gates
what was the comment earlier this week
tom brady didn't even know where to sit
when he when he uh showed up on the
sidelines for the first game
week nine they got blown out it went
sideways early and that was that
this is a full year now of tom brady 17
games of tom brady playing with the
buccaneers
he knows that offense so much better
they know him so much better is a far
different team than it was and i think
psychologically the fact that the saints
won the first two games
gives the buccaneers a powerful edge in
this one
also three straight years now the saints
have had their hearts ripped out and
shown to them in the playoffs at some
point
and how can you not feel like that's
coming if you're a saints player
devon white devin white he's back
his return inside linebacker who's in a
second team all pro
to have him back there with levante
david will certainly give him a chance
to run around and deal with camaro and
all that other stuff it's gonna be a
great weekend
we'll see you all saturday night as we
get you ready for the bills
and the ravens in our nbc game enjoy
this
best weekend of the year divisional
playoffs and we will see you
over the weekend hi i'm mike tarico
and thanks for watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights
from nbc sports